[Music]
Justin Bieber and Haley Baldwin heating
up romance rumors in Miami
what do you check out the payer outside
live nightclub in Miami on Sunday the
Biebs rocking a black hoodie and red
plaid pants Haley and a skin-tight silk
slip dress with sneakers and I witnessed
lzt they seemed very flirty inside the
club and left together after 3 a.m.
holding hands and hopping into a black
Escalade he's just really sweet he's a
good kid it's a good heart and I love
him the couple who dated in 2015 and
split in 2016 also spent Monday together
take a look at this cozy shot Justin
shirtless and toweling off while Haley
helps him out kids are not to notice the
smile on her face does your dad like him
that's the big question
most recently the Biebs reconciles with
ex Selena Gomez while Haley was linked
to Shawn Mendes after they attended the
Met Gala together last month although he
told DT this just after no we're not
dating but it was it was so fun too and
Haley is one of the coolest and most
special people I've ever met
you